Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is going
to be a breakdown of the new Christmas Special
Cip that played during Children in Need.
The big thing was that it confirmed Clara
would be in it.
Jenna Coleman and Moffat have made a few comments
recently about what’s happening in the episode
and Missy in General so I’ll start with
that.
New Round of the giveaway starts now, all
you need to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Because we’re in Doctor Who limbo in terms
of official new content I’m making a few
changes to my video schedule that I’ll explain
at the end of this.
Christmas and Clara Time.
Jenna Coleman did a very general interview
unrelated to Doctor Who but the Special and
her potentially leaving the show came up.
She said the Special is all about dreaming,
about what’s real and what’s not.
That’s a very opaque explanation but as
we saw in the teaser Nick Frost as Father
Christmas or Santa, whatever you want to call
him.
Asking Clara why she stopped believing in
As much as episodes of Doctor Who center on
The Doctor, this feels like it might be a
story told from Clara’s perspective.
As if in the course of the adventure they
have, Clara suddenly decides that Father Christmas
is real.
That doesn’t mean Nick Frost’s character
is not some advanced alien acting as Father
Christmas, It seems like that’s what’s
really going on.
But Father Christmas and The Doctor share
a lot of the same abilities.
The ability to travel to everyone’s house
in the span of
a single night.
And containers that are bigger on the inside.
When you think about it, isn’t the TARDIS
like a giant bag of gifts.
Not always the gifts you want, but always
the gifts you need.
Here’s some background on the scene that
we can use to spin some theories:
Clara is seen with Father Christmas first
but The TARDIS has already landed behind her.
Even though his sleigh is parked at a weird
angle and there are gifts spilled out all
over the place I don’t think it crashed.
It’s implied The Doctor has a pre-existing
relationship with Father Christmas and there
is an urgent matter they are both involved
in that requires Clara.
I don’t think Father Christmas is an evil
character like Missy.
So I don’t think The Doctor is trying to
save Clara from imminent demise.
He asks her to get her ass in the TARDIS no
questions asked.
But based on his interaction with Father Christmas
I think they need her to help solve a problem
at the North Pole and there’s a ticking
clock.
Time is running out.
We know that the episode takes place primarily
at The North Pole at this place and these
people are the supporting cast.
This place where they are here is back where
Clara is living now.
The creature in the last trailer looks kind
of like an Ice Warrior without it’s armor
and for a little bit he might be coming after
Nick Frosts people.
Like this is they mythological Santa’s Workshop
and this creature is the proverbial Grinch
trying to ruin Christmas by killing them all.
That’s just a fun Doctor Who Doctor Seuss
crossover theory but based on what Jenna Coleman
said in her interview and her conversation
with Nick Frost in the clip.
Believing in Father Christmas is a core part
of the solution.
So there’s the A story about Clara believing
in made up things that might be totally real
like Father Christmas or Robin Hood or The
Doctor.
And there’s the B Story - The monster chase
with this creature.
The BBC will continue to post new clips and
promos between now and the special, so fingers
crossed that there’s more new footage that
can explain how the A story and the B story
come together.
And why Clara is so important to it all.
Next big question is Clara leaving or not
leaving.
That same interview Jenna Coleman did mentioned
her plans after Doctor Who.
It didn’t say when that was happening but
she answered by saying she was just going
to chill, do some theater and start going
to auditions again.
She said that because Doctor Who was such
a big commitment, she hasn’t had much time
to audition for other shows or movies since
becoming a companion.
None of that specifically said she was leaving
in the Christmas Special but if all the major
news sources are hinting she might leave,
there’s probably some truth to the rumors.
Moffat has confirmed he’s back for Series
9.
He’s already writing the first episode but
they probably won’t film it till after he’s
done filming the Sherlock Christmas Special
in january.
Which I will totally do bonus videos for.
Sherlock that is when they start filming.
Be sure to subscribe to get that stuff.
The two best Clara theories I’ve seen are
that she’s flat out leaving at the end of
the Christmas Special or she’s doing the
Donna to Martha transition thing where she
stays on for a few episodes of series 9 while
the new companion comes in.
As a way to ease the swap.
Let me know in the comments, why do you think
Clara is so important to The Doctor and Nick
Frost and when do you think she’s leaving
the show?
Since I’m not doing a Q&A video for this
they giveaway will just stay open till I post
my next Doctor Who video.
I might take next weekend off unless a new
Trailer posts but be sure to follow me on
twitter and facebook for video updates.
I’ll probably post two to three more bonus
videos between now and the week of Christmas.
Then during that week I’ll do a bunch of
Doctor Who.
And Sherlock.
Lots of Sherlock videos in January too.
I’m really excited about it.
In the meantime, click here for my finale
video and click here to start catching up
on Sherlock Series 4.
Thanks for watching, high fives everybody.
See ya tonight!